hey guys it is the 15 so december today
my name is Jess Mattel and you're
watching it if you're a fan of devil may
cry today's totally your day since
Capcom have announced a couple of things
happening for franchise first up devil
may cry for special edition is in the
works and set to come to xbox one and
ps4 in the summer of next year the game
was originally released for the 360 ps3
and pc in 2008 on top of that the 2013
reboot DMC Devil May Cry is also coming
to ps4 and xbox one on much 17 of 2015
as the definitive edition the game will
cost you 40 bucks and will run at 1080p
and 60 frames per second develop an
inter theory of karma thing rebalance to
gameplay all the dear see a bunch of new
modes and a wildly tricky difficulty
level old gods must die among other
features you can check out all the
details in our story on gamespot we'd
already heard that the witcher 3 was
going to feature a female playable
character but today we have to find out
all about who she is well the story is
still about girls the character named
Siri finds herself a target of the
nefarious Wild Hunt CD Projekt RED
explains a descendant in a long-lost
elven blood lineage theory plays an
important role in The Witcher law she is
called a powerful living weapon capable
of both healing and destroying the world
she inhabits in regards to actually
playing as her the studio have said that
she unlocks narrative possibilities and
happens to be a pretty wicked sword
fighter with several of her own unique
abilities Microsoft have been riding the
halo train for a good while now and
apparently they intend to keep doing so
for another decade
that's according to 343 industries boss
Bonnie Ross who told publication
Bloomberg that went three-for-three was
formed in 2007 the series was six years
old and she wanted to ensure it could go
for another 30 years Ross had said that
she hopes to get away from numbered
hailer releases allowing for more
spin-offs and also expressed her
enthusiasm for diversity in the 343
industries studio she explained that
having women in key roles in the
industry is really important and for
halo having heroic men and women that
people can identify with was a goal ask
you a question of the day let me know if
you're up for another few decades of
Halo and why or why not you can head to
gain swap for stories on Lindsay Lohan's
game and Microsoft's bearing on the Xbox
one that is it for me today i'll be back
same time tomorrow with a bunch of my
news but we try to have yourselves a
good one until then